[Music]
could you and I talk for a second yeah
we go somewhere and talk
sure Josiah just came in the kitchen and
said the you were talking about we're
supposed to have a day and I walk away I
say only what has happened I asked you
what are you doing and even you say
nothing okay we can make dinner together
and go enjoy a new jacuzzi you say yes I
go in a kitchen for before dinner and
changed my clothes for for for today the
jacuzzis for yeah nobody can go in there
because it's twofold
it doesn't matter to date in jacuzzi or
a date here well it doesn't matter for
me so why didn't you I say
Claire why don't we work going on he was
not in the kitchen I sitting like I'm in
the house though I don't go in the
living room for a woman but I say
everything is fine really
it's not fine it's not fine if you feel
this way and you're telling these guys
this stuff it's okay really it's not
okay
I swear it's okay for me I'll listen for
me this is not okay okay I'm doing the
best I can I don't think so but it's
okay
[Music]